thank you very much thank you Richard
I'm very pleased to be here not only
because I like a Stanford and I've been
as Richard said very well I've been that
at Stanford for a number of years I was
in 1988 let me brief you give you the
context of the presentation tonight in
the in to follow water was just said I
started to be interested in Asia in the
early 60s and went to Japan for five
years and when I read at that time if
you remember 6167 6267 was your lamp
Peaks was a Japan was as directing and
when I returned to Europe in the 67
Ariana I went to business school college
dad and I went there because I saw to
that the state of the planet was not so
good at that time and it's even worse
now but if the state of the plant was so
bad maybe we could do something with
chief executive business leaders because
they have a great amount of
responsibility for what is happening in
the world so I decided to go to a
business school and then to work with
MBAs and typical equity and so forth and
I realized at that time that the
European were haha ignorant about Japan
and a potential generally speaking so I
built a center for her asian research
for the euro-asia Center which I run for
a number of years and in 1988 and then
at that time I realized that it was
quite important to try to run enhances
the understanding of Asia in Europe
particularly the responsibility
dimension and at that time if you
remember in the 1990s as an the
interests in Japan they shifted because
Japan got into a number of problem at
that time and I concentrate and
observing china china was just emerging
from the cultural revolution and then on
that watching what was happening i could
see there was of course this fantastic
grows his extraordinary development or
speed of taking 600 I'll so many people
out of poverty it was wonderful but
same time there was a number of
dysfunction and then I thought that
maybe I could they spend some time in
China to work with a senior executive
and maybe a very small scale or a very
very modesto scale I could influence as
a way of handling and managing
state-owned enterprise or private
companies and I decided at that time to
go to to Chong guy to cibc IBS which was
a best which is probably one of the best
business school in China and they gave
me freedom to develop a center for
leadership and responsibility so I
started to I started to work there with
MBAs and also with middle managers in
executive education also with chief
executive and out of that I have learned
a number of thing about China and I
would like to share with you in that
context what I have learned and how does
he how is this relevant given the
subject that Richard is developing in
this industry center and particularly in
this course so I would ask me to talk
about some of the consequence of the
economic slowdown and there's an about
corruption so that's what I will do
first I will say a few words about Z
slow down and suggest that term so we
all know of the many issues that the
Japanese confronted 20 is we we should
realize that the government is quite
aware and the government is a very keen
to do something about it and it has as
you have as we have seen the major over
the last a few years the government
particularly with the new team very keen
to try to take action and they want to
encourage the private business I want to
help small indigence I enterprise I want
to decrease the important of SME after
SOE and they want to simplify the
administration to make it easier for the
entrepreneur to start having non SI so
complex bureaucratic system which is
very time-consuming they wanted to
modify the tax receipt so they have a
very rich diverse plans to
to alleviate some of the problem which
exists for the entrepreneur with the
developing his business in China they
want to decent Halai to give more
responsibility to probe in but at the
same time decentralized some of the
things so it's a kind of complex a wee
decentralized but at the same time for a
few things we will do it in in Beijing
because we want to avoid some obvious
thing which happened in the province
better to do it in Beijing and as I want
to apply solo they say no we need to be
who we need to have the whole of the
road to be the gospel of development and
I think it is a challenging it is a
challenge to do that for for for the
Technic hardly expert or the party
member in Beijing and there are a number
of dysfunction which are quite visible
today and to manage at the same time a
transformation of China to make China
more open to start up to entrepreneurs
to cultivate innovation at the same time
we realized that they are some decisions
which have been made which are not
really conducive to this creative
development is innovation and
environment where you can develop a
number of a new initiative so I then
there didn't I understand the logic of
the clearly the management of in China
or no one realized that innovation is a
must ah you cannot capitalize too long
for their cheap labor and soon this the
reservoir of workers coming from the
countryside is going to dry a little bit
because they will go not anymore to show
his cause but they will go into the new
cities which are developing in the in
the south of China and so we need to
develop productivity if we want to cope
with as a consequence of aging
population we will have less people in
the edge of working we really need to
cultivate innovation so I think that's
offer a number of opportunity for
the entrepreneur who is the one who
after being educated he or someone who
has been educated in China to start his
own enterprise and to develop a start-up
as many as I said here you could see i
see many opportunities in these sectors
in this particular sectors and and the
government is pushing into that
direction and want to walk the talk not
only to say welcome to do this we are
going to do that we are going to clean
up the country we are going to clean up
the environment we have been to stop
pollution and so forth they are they
trying to do something about it I will
take one of the issues because that was
what I was invited to a to talk about
which is this corruption issue when I
was at in China I discussed with amb I
chose embs at length for for nearly six
years emba our noses thousands of you
are not familiar MBA are too kind of em
evening courses or weekend cause it they
it's a group of 60 60 at the times they
come 16 time on the two-year period for
four days each month so they come friday
saturday sunday monday identical hidden
to company and so cuenta q that the
number of time and i was doing some
teaching in that for four years and when
I discussed about corruption which I so
conviction has a real issue I think
often pollute so many different
dimension of the China environment not
only in MIDI column not only was a
doctor but with the university with with
developing a level playing field it has
a great impact so I try to discuss with
them and I was surprised in 2005 to 2010
that they told me well it has always
existed you know collection is not
really a problem is not the development
look at where we are everyone comes to
China as a whole it wonderful how
extraordinary development you have it
exists everywhere you have it in your
country and in fact we do have a few
minister in jail in my country and are
you could say is a says well II it is a
hang-up of the West the comment yourself
but this is corruption in fact it is not
corruption it is a parallel income
distribution system
or we have no choice and it's true that
yes but you know if you want to do
business this is a way to do it and it's
all the machine it works very smoothly
and if I don't if I don't do it then I
shoot myself in the foot my competitor
her probably and we do better than I do
I don't call it corruption ah I don't do
it as outsourced Micronesian problem I
have mr. fix you fix it from me we have
a budget we plant that this is aware and
in your country will give a tip in my
country we give a top it's about the
same but I at that time I told them but
you know you were Prime Minister is with
a different view he says we got to do
something about it undo the oh yah he
talks just investing you're right in
Beijing yes but you know it's okay and
then five years later we could see that
the government says it is really a
problem are we really need to do
something about it we got to catch up a
few people it has all kind of
dysfunction image income distribution
and bending the road so we need to do
something about it and they walk the
talk another leak ack young moccasin
today so there you know we a new team so
we really need to do something about it
and we are going to do it and they
explains the reason why i said you know
it has all kinds of negative
consequences and we want to be a country
where there is a rule of law so
assessing being in the same way say say
we got to cash not unless is small fly
but also the Tigers and they actually a
walk the talk there is a catch a few
people in fact quite a few with them in
jail or sometimes shorter in a bit their
life sometime Bacchus and they said you
know of course it's difficult to do that
but we have to do it we have to do we
have to clean up any catch a few tigers
and if you we don't know exactly what
will happen but
some died in jail like Caillou who was
it but the government is trying to it we
said you know we don't really talk about
it like previous generation of leaders
not only we talk button we having to do
something about it and that is one of
the latest case as you heard when that
was a tiger that was relieved a tiger on
the tiger or boomboxen I before was also
so this illustrate the fact that aware
of the issues having full power now
teaching ping as all power he can really
implement what he says he would want to
implement and he does a number of people
have been brought up and it has all kind
of consequences for entrepreneur not
only they try to catch those who are in
the in the outside the China but they
also want to make sure that the Gacha
those were most visible whether they are
those who don't share with you or not we
have to lock them up so I think it has
several important consequences it has
changed the mindset of the civil servant
of the officials are not only know you
cannot play golf now that you are told
Gulf is not of course officially is
because we don't have enough water so
because we are looking for a job we
cannot maintain those golf club and
therefore work but anyways if
interventions going to golf because you
know this is a nest for developing
personal relationship which is and then
luxury you have seen that in sir
pressure of an emba you know away we see
now cips for instance that OMB is a
number of participate in emba it was
executive i was mentioning earlier now
they drop in the middle of the proteges
to you are aware when you can have a
program the drop-ins Amidala and you say
why don't you why did you stop and they
say well my brother told me and now we
are not supposed to go to those courses
because those course has a nest for
corruption because I dreams of course
you have the civil servant or provincial
local of city or from Beijing we
developed with private entrepreneur and
run their relationship and the
government think that this is the seed
for her corruption so they have that
asked to refrain and now the ass
business going to refund them from a
nutrition fee because they have not
completed to call but that's another
issue many government official sanction
as we will have to declare the personal
Isetta this is also present for some of
them are also complain that the income
is going to shrink a little bit we have
more case of civil servant we decided to
shorten the life on and G civil service
job is maybe that has less attractive
because now you cannot get the benefit
that you used to have before through
this parallel distribution and the but
it has also a benefit in order for
normal citizen they have now easier
access officially it is slow very slow
maybe decision-making good people don't
dare to make decision but in terms of
the administrative an odd shape as i
said earlier the governments want to
decrease red tape so for other citizen
it is a benefit and maybe those as a
party will get some the party will get
some better image because they said you
know they are trying to catch up those
whether somebody delinquent in terms of
income has a ring and this is a good
thing it will clean up the place so it
has
potential benefit whether it will have a
long time in fact maybe you will tell us
a little bit more about it house let me
ask one follow-up question okay before
we switch over to June and my follow-up
question is that you know in a business
culture like China where guanxi and is a
part of doing business probably the sort
of distinction between corruption and
acceptable guanxi really is a relative
thing that depends on the sort of social
acceptability in a particular situation
and that's remarkably well understood
inside a culture if you do more than
this it's a bribe if you don't if you do
up to this point then that's looking out
for each other you know taking care of
each other's hedging risk or whatever
but they use any more clarity in this or
do you think that the new system is
actually less clear but it has to do
with where do you draw the line you know
if I invite you for lunch and we have a
nice lunch together because we want to
do business or you want to obtain some
virtualization for me and we have a nice
lunch and this is probably all right if
you give me a couple of all X and then
you fry my children due to application
on my children at Stanford I mean the
average that is a bit too much so where
do we say this is okay this is a bit ins
of fringes this is too far and current
lame the government might have wanted to
be extremely strict and then to says the
whole of the game is you cannot you
cannot receive this and then I says
there but that's nice to say but you
know we need to do with the whole kind
of including the tradition including the
giv giving we are in a society where we
exchange gift it's a norm of reciprocity
you scratch my back I scratch your back
you give me this optimization and I give
you a box of X oh yeah ok we can come
back because I think this is one of the
most three points to really consider is
what's socially acceptable and what
isn't it's right
in the meantime I'd like to ask June if
you would give us your comments I think
we can switch over automatically to your
slides right and I like your title the
new normal in China yeah thank you thank
you Richard um first of all is my
pleasure to be here I come speak at
micro level as a professor Henry been
difficult but i will speak from my own
experience so first of all I was boring
in kind of late 70s I spend most of my
time study in china i came to united
states in 1997 to pursue graduate school
and and ever since i stayed in US but
everyone's well actually quite
frequently i travel back to china and
now i work for this chinese-based a
company for almost 80 years and i
actually experienced it quite a bit wav
i'm going to which i'm going to talk
about which related to the
entrepreneurship yeah so can we go to
the neck yeah let's go to the next slice
so before I jump into answering actually
before I come to this talk Professor
Richard a Dasher actually asked me to
talk about today's topics related to the
Entrepreneurship the the new economics
and I happening in China's and so before
I answer that let me give you a quick it
you know what minute intro about being
soft so beyond softly is a kind of a
exemplar of a Chinese enterprise that
was founded in nineteen ninety-five
about 20 years ago and it started with
providing software actually the labors
to do the computer in a developer
testing work and we actually went public
in China at first we want to go public
in US this is happening in 2008 but we
run into it you know
economy yeah no problems yeah so we
couldn't go public here at that time we
have a difficult time to raise money and
then in 2009 we actually made a decision
to go public in China and you know
because of accounting issue we spend a
counting difference between US and China
we spent like two years to create I mean
to work on our company so end of story
went public in 2012 and now the you know
the company is growing really well at
the current stage we did really well
among all of our competitors however in
terms of the consulting outsourcing
business in China we run into huge issue
which is the the labor cost in China has
gone up so hugely so the company is in
need of transformation that's why we
actually form the US and start up
investment in which i am currently
leading so that's kind of a brief
history of bounce off to calculate the
company's 9,000 people worldwide we we
are public company we have a global
global delivery center in China in us in
Japan in Singapore in India and also a
few offices and also in Canada and we
actually did the several more junk with
acquisitions including US company
including Canadian companies including
Indian companies so the you know we're
pretty proud pretty proud of ourselves
as a global company we grow pretty well
but however we also are facing the
challenge of how we continue to lead in
this market so to answer the professor
dashers question let's go to nexus slice
i want to talk about the five waves of
entrepreneurship happened in china since
90 49 so my xperia have personal
experience on some you know I don't for
example the first one the 1978
that's the kind of the the first wave of
innovation happens I startups in ways
that is when the government decided to
lose the control give the control back
to the patterns to the two farmers so
that time the startups is happening in
in the suburban areas when people
actually have control over land they
decided that they don't have to form
this kind of conglomerate in teams and
they have their own individual drives
that you to plan what to know what what
to farms and the second wave is happen
unfortunately the first one I didn't
explore that was too young but the
second one which is happening in 1984 I
was still pretty I I wasn't part of it
but I observed during that time the
Chinese i actually have have the
open-door policy and I thought I my dad
was one of the first kind of a wave to
go to change in the area he's architect
at that time there are a lot of
happenings in the schengen being the
first city in the entire China to try
out this open door policy and during
that time in that wave many new
companies such as higher you might solve
you might hair is the one of the Chinese
electronic brand that they sell the TV
sell the refrigerators so at that time
the manufacturer manufacturers and in
factories that is when the startup waves
not you know mostly in place and China
becomes one of the global center for the
manufacturing and and I think in the
past 20 years you would see you know the
the huge labor surplus an advantage that
actually impacted the Chinese growth
today so in 1984 that's when the
manufacturing and startups in the
opportunity happens
and in night the third waves comes in
1992 and that time I was in college um
so that way was led by the the China
elite knowledge worker so the at that
time so you know again the policy
becomes you know even bodily opened and
in real estate insurance in education
you know we see the entrepreneurs and
those are really knowledgeable people so
unlike the firsta to and farmers or you
know the factory leaders and this survey
was led by the knowledge worker one of
the example is called this company
called a new oriental um Shindong hyung
so i think at that time almost all the
students who wants to come to us to
study they have to you know receive
education from this from this firm
because they provide english training
exam training and they become so popular
and that house in college actually i
have taken their class and to prepare to
come for coming to us and the for the
fourth wave um is the internet wave and
i think the the people who let this is
actually my age or maybe a little older
than me so the current the the three
largest internet company in china we
call it a ba t by dou tungsten Tencent
and Alibaba they're all the founders and
CEOs are all born in that in that in a
little older than me or like my age and
they founded the company during that
time and the LA you know the 5th wave
and I would say is now or it's actually
I think this way will be led by the
millions the people who born after 1980s
and after 1990s and in my own opinion
and the opportunity will be because the
new basically
new generations they are experiencing
everything different from my age or the
older age because the when they were
born when they grow up you know social
internet are just you know they take it
for granted and they they were brought
up by connected at the social networks
right and and their opinion towards
worries and also you know much open and
also the applied to the traditional
industries because of the innovation of
Internet the way people are are doubling
doing the business are so different so I
would say this way from you know we
would see traditional business will be
disrupted you know coming to the
opportunity for example the 0 to 0 is
very very popular in China it will stand
for online to offline and you know
because of the Chinese huge populations
and you will see the opportunities of
having you know like neo services
delivered services come to your door
steps you know this is one of the way to
disrupt it the dinners and also in the
marketplace like you know overs and we
have similar a enterprise in China
thought id Software um that's the
marketplace is actually also disrupted
the traditional way of not doing the
business yeah so can we go to the next
one um so you know why why is this is
happening in my own opinion because the
past 20 years the China's huge growth
was due to the labor surplus the cost of
the labor is so low and so the first is
happening in the manufacturer later is
the you know for example in my
industry's software outsourcing you know
I joined the company in 2007 but the
company actually all sourcing industry
in China was booming in two thousand six
to two thousand eight and you know it's
just at that time you know it's so easy
to get
new business because everybody want to
all sorts to China you know we got
talents we you know we got the you know
a huge market of the talents and trained
trained the software engineers so and
also I had the one fifth of the cost of
the u.s. here right so at that time you
know it's such an easy thing to to kind
of a convince the customers they have
and you know have your have a team in
China you know they're smart they're
really hard working but if we look at
today you know the cost that has in
China has been continuously go up right
and a lot of clients saying hey you know
considering about the communication has
the hassles and Layton sees and you know
it's not as attractive as before and
that's all one challenge we're facing
the second challenge is the you know the
market in China are so growing so well
and all the talents that we used to be
you know if the if a worker quit the job
for us they will go to competitors and
or they want to come to us but now it's
not like that the first two choices go
to the Baidu ten senton and Alibaba or
or even work for the state owned the
company you know they have this seems to
have better opportunity instead of you
know working for even like melty
national companies yeah so right now you
know the labor talents the scars even in
China for the China market so it which
presented a pretty challenging job for
us right and and look at the entire
China's so in the past 20 years ago we
have this a huge labor surplus but
nowadays is a little different and also
the fundamental of the country in the
past was built on the manufacturing
advantage but now it's changed because
of the environmental issue because of
the huge surplus and so the company the
country itself needs to change to have
it to develop a new york or competence
the in the global competition however we
also have so many people that we need to
feed make sure they have jobs right so
we can't say hey the all the factories
we cut down because we don't have that
nice but then you know so many people
will be out of job right so the country
itself actually the new leader has a
pretty challenging job to do so that's
why you know the you see this new policy
come out because the economy needs to be
restructured probably towards the
service more service in the industry and
being developed instead of manufacturing
and you know due to the labor cost
increase and second of all I think the
access they need to be reallocated the
country itself the really promote
entrepreneurship now they want
individuals to to really be creative to
be proactive but you know doing the job
that's why you see those this new policy
come out and the encouragement of the
the Entrepreneurship I think it to the
individuals I would say is a great great
time to start a company in China there's
so many athletes that you know the
capitals around I think that because of
the surplus less cumulated past 20 20
years and in individuals in the and also
this like the company's halves collect a
huge asset they need to reinvest into
the future right so when that actually
you see you know so many companies are
doing what I am doing yeah it's actually
creating fund or participating funded so
that because they want to invest in the
new technologies because the older
companies and competitive advantage in
the longer exists and then we have to
make sure that we continue to investing
in the talents in the new innovations so
so it's a great time to for the
individuals to to start a company in
china and
the enterprise I have said a lot of them
are doing investment why actually
started this new role actually I took a
trip back to China talk to all of my you
know friends who are doing Westerman
were connected in this and you know I
was from Beijing so I spent some time in
Beijing i visit the incubator you would
be amazed that how many incubators they
are it's like it's like a Silicon Valley
you know across the street do you see
you see quite a few you know coffee shop
there actually incubators and I think of
Beijing was growing really fast it to be
probably the word a second yeah you know
in a way take place in the whole world
lies it's just growing so fast yeah yeah
so oh how much time do I have can we
yeah so can I go to the Nexus slice yeah
so um so professor dasher asked me you
know whether whether the anti-corruption
will impact the oversea interact
investment right um and and I I would
say if you say that will if
anti-corruption will decrease the
oversea investment that that means
there's assumption that in the past the
in a corruption actually supported with
the oversea investor I don't know but
you know personally I would say this the
anti-corruption will not impact oh well
naughty decrease how the overseeing
investment happens yeah are you thinking
mostly about out going overseas
investment from China or about incoming
overseas investment to China I'm
thinking of all going yeah yeah well my
only experience there are a lot of the
Capitals that looking for investment
overseas one isn't too kind of diversify
the risk right you come just invested
everything within China because that's
too risky
a lot of valuation in China is already
pretty high and and also the channels
the investment are limited so and also
if you look at the government policies
actually supporting this in action the
country self actually really encourage
the enterprise to do more oversee
investment and like in February this
year and i was i was looking at my which
had I somebody posted this for me it's
actually the is for like a demonstration
of foreign exchange in China actually
published a policy in February that they
can it used to be if a firm wants to do
the oversea investment that they will
have to fouling some approval to get
approval from the foreign exchange in a
bureau but now they actually lose the
control it says you no longer need to do
that and everything needs to happen at
the bank so they actually to make sure
the policy is actually come very similar
to what is happening here and they
simplified of the process that made it
the the form is much easier to do future
you know investment here you know and I
was so excited I send it to our CEO and
immediately he gave the thumbs up yeah
because that's just to making the
process much simpler and that's just one
example is actually the China government
is actually really supporting the firms
and capitals to do over seamaster meant
and they yeah and and also the trend I
have seen is the you know a lot of VCS I
talk to you you know they really look
into China market and supporting that
and and also in addition it they're
actively looking for talents and IPS you
know and teams and are able to operate
in in a global market or they can come
back to China and support the future
growth of China so one example
I think recently there's the acquisition
of the segway I think most people
probably are familiar with that this
kind of yeah so Sega was acquired by
this Chinese company called a my bot
yeah so that's I think that because my
bod believes that the opposition will
actually allow them to gain the IP
access and also allow them to be able to
expand in the global market I think you
sell us a little more about the
acquiring Chinese company whose my boss
are they really big uh I believe they
then they're growing really fast is
number one the they do similar things as
in the segue but primarily only in China
yeah and I think that I heard the
machine was and I use that by policemen
and please department and something like
that yeah yeah okay that's great I have
just kind of a follow-up for you if i am
to understand what you think is the new
normal in china more disruptive business
more disruptive business ideas and
that's a huge change right because if
you're disrupting business ideas then
that is a threat to the existing power
relationships at least in the corporate
world not necessarily in the government
right but one of the reasons for a lot
of the intensely personal nature of
business in china was essentially
protecting your business position where
you don't rely as much on court cases of
intellectual property infringement as
you do on who you know who will
administer some legal action it's a good
question i think the coming to the china
culture human relationship is always
going to be very very important right
and but in terms of the dealing into the
business you see more impact when you if
you you are going to have a startup you
will see relationship is more
importantly when you
do b2b business than b2c business right
so some of the disruptive the way I see
the actually shorten the flow there may
be used to be so many min amends
actually the new processes I should get
rid of the middleman sins so that
exactly sets up my next question are you
seeing more new b2c plays 'wouldn't
startup companies or are you seeing a
lot of activity in the b2b space I think
in BOS but b2b will be smaller slower
because if you look at the wood the 55
waves I was talking about in the past
you know the most startups / well in the
area where is less control so less
control means the exactly the it's more
like a free market and people compare
you know startups in China actually
compete at the much more intense level
on here if you have one startup doing
things a good thing and making money
there will tomorrow you will find maybe
four or five doing similar things so you
really have to compete in the
operational level and I think in in a in
the b2c area there's actually last
control and allow more try fail this and
that's why you actually see more
opportunities there and be 2 b's is
still you know controlled by by quincy
or religions i think that that's it
that's it even same in us because we
have when you're working in the large
enterprise you know I would I want to
work with you for a long time 10 years
20 years so that's why whether you're
credible is very very important it's
different from P to see you know I put
an order on your platform if I it's a
bad transaction I just forget it that I
walk away but in in the b2b you know
area a you know the racing is much
higher so I that's why you know Chinese
people associated when she with
credibility's and you know because
there's no such the okay the quite
assistant is not so let me
up in for a second and point out that
both of our panelists have said that in
some ways the increase in transparency
and increase in sort of better business
processes that you can expect from the
corruption crackdown maybe that's also
intensified by an economic slowdown
where you have to be more efficient you
have to be more careful that's one thing
but I once really at the center of my
question for both of you and let's start
with the question if you're starting a
company in China is it easier to get
market access under the current
situation or is was it easier to get
market access five or ten years ago and
I think that market access is a key and
you really do need to look separately at
B to C vs b2b okay um professor
depending a note on your comment or you
could use comment on the role of the
personal relationship and wet we just
heard from june and i think for the
startup for the young entrepreneur who
develop his business it is more
difficult for him to have access to
government connection and then if you
will work for a large soe and therefore
that he's a car handicap because your
social capital your capacity to
influence and to accelerate decision is
a bit too more modest than if you work
for a well-known is a multinational or
four state-owned enterprise now that was
a particular point on the transparency
and the fact that the government is
pushing for transparency is that the
consequence of the economic slowdown yes
and no i think yes it is because the
government realized that if the economy
is going below seven percent is 6.8 or
this is going to create number of
employment problem as the June said we
need to create the job for all those
graduate
out of university and to make sure that
we have enough to you to give them
something and use the economy goes down
as a job creation is going to be maybe a
bit more modest and therefore we need to
do everything to prevent this to happen
one way is to try to attract more
foreign investors or to have more
development here school more
transparency because everyone complained
that the lack of transparency is the
opacity of the system slow down decision
prevent some decision to be made so if
we really wanted to get this economy
increasing productivity and coping with
the recession but coping with the
decrease of the activity we need to a
transparency will be a useful instrument
it will give more access to foreign
company to what we are doing it will
give us a better image it will
accelerate possibly the decision-making
process in reality it may not achieve
that because the cb7 as I said seems to
be now a bit more reluctant to take
decision because we might get into a
some sticky situation so initially this
transformation of the economies is this
reform that the government is bringing
may not bring immediately as we expected
result expected I would come partly
because people don't quite know how to
go through the process of reform if it
slows down decision-making that would be
a negative impact right and the
prevention other provinces that he says
those people in beijing or top of the
mountain telling them what to do is I've
always been a bit reluctant to implement
decision from the central government so
now that the central government is
having this very strong a behavior
toward a certain type of copper weight
of individual behavior if you are in the
province that yes you will say yes okay
we will change we
adopt adapted to what the government
want but definitely so it may create
some integrity if not antagonism some
resentment you know some of my friend
are now in jail you know some of my
friend have to enclose themselves or
someone united states have been brought
back so today I will be very careful I
don't want to be caught into this
process now that's mostly the attitudes
of people in the public sector in the
government sector right in the business
sector are people more concerned because
of this or are they more aggressive
because of this I don't want to
monopolize it I'm looking at both of you
I'll either either person oh that's a
tough question um well that yeah that's
sort of difficult question that I think
the you know anti anti corruptions my
made things harder to do you know
because in the past days is easier
people having incentives to do things
right and now one thing now is the you
know where's the incentives and the
negative the downside is obvious the
upside is less yeah but the but the
government officials that these days
also have restricted kpi's you know key
performance indicator you know whether
you're perform or not perform and if you
want to go to go up in the chain you
have to actually show real performance
right so if you act you know Seema lay
offs that is created in your district or
the number of jobs created in your
district the amount of taxes from your
district no yard they have to show you
know what's economic economic growth so
you have brought it to the area nothing
he had now is precisely because of that
the government is trying to change the
sale you see sean has decided not to
reward people and to use as a main
incentive a quantitative performance and
the GNP development for the Shanga area
because he arrived that is perverse
effect everyone will try to
and make sure that they deliver because
of the KPI is the objective and in order
to do so I will let company to pollute
because if I give them a fine or hips I
close them I create an employment in my
they don't pay taxes and my income is
income of the cities or lower so I have
more incentive to try to go as fast as
possible and demonstrate my province is
doing better than yours our pockets and
now the gonna say yes this has created
so many negative consequences this over
investment over capacity is all kinds of
finishing taking place now we are not
going to reward you according to the
actual their quantitative performance
you will have to include a number of
qualitative element in order that the
assessment of your performance will be
more comprehensive so June back to this
whole point about market access
especially in the b2b sector and one
reason I'm asking about this is because
if China follows the same sort of
general path of economic development
that we saw in Japan and then in South
Korea you're going to see the big
companies worried about protecting
themselves and not doing a good job of
interacting with startup companies now
that's a different thing from the
economic slowdown in itself but
certainly as an economy advanced as you
expect a slowing of gdp growth and you
know the the I think you had a large
part of the Japanese economy a large
part of the Korean economy that was
essentially controlled by a relatively
small number of large companies and so
b2b became not the way to be an
entrepreneur in those countries well in
China I think unlike in Japan or a
career the most i mean the the business
b2b marketer was controlled by family
you know they're privately owned but in
china is different the largest asset was
controlled by country it's a state-owned
enterprise right so that's that's very
different okay there's there's no you
know private owned enterprise actually
are able to control any of the
really significant or resources it's
actually that is up to the country the
government to decide you know how to let
the rule play you know so for example in
the past you know the girl everybody
knows china has a really huge
environmental issue right but in the
past though you don't see very
successful companies that actually
addressing that that's because the
policy wasn't there now we're hoping
that in the the car no government would
actually they're actually working very
hard early on setting up the policy and
have it open so then so I startups
actually can start working on that yeah
so well this is an area that you don't
hear talked about in the discussion of
the crackdown and that's the the heads
of the SOS are they acting more like
public employees are they acting more
like private business people or
certainly acting more than they had been
the state-owned enterprises civil
servant types have a very confortable
lives are not so competitive is a very
well protected some of them advocacy
monopoly situation so is every
comfortable and now the government see I
best is going to change you know we are
going to open the market working through
that private sector to get into your
business in the railroad industry in
different industry in our private sector
can come that's going to stimulate and
you overpaid so we are going to decrease
your compensation however what is this
and so forth so as easy as SOE are
currently in a turbulent around and that
appointment is made by the visor visor
party so you have to behave in a way
that made you make sure your career
followers the gospel also assesses in
m of the party so I think so you were
mentioning about the relationship
between SOE and private and do a small
start-up I think and now that he allies
because of the pressure of the
government that innovation is a master
and they know that the innovation will
come probably more from startup than
from a bigger and larger SOE they will
go into that direction in a way the
Sussex is pushing them into that
direction but between what's a sarcasm
to do and what they do that is some time
and some time lag or some dissonance ok
thank you let's open up the Florida
questions if you would briefly identify
yourself and also say which of our
panelists if or both you would like to
address the question to go ahead buck GA
was a former executive cisco systems i
retired but i spent three years in the
valley um there in the press in looking
at the anti-corruption movement there's
some skepticism whether it's really anti
corruption or whether it's a political
purge I'm just curious what you see and
how it starts viewed in China you said
that it is a just political process to
get rid of people we don't share your
view I think that is a much too
simplistic interpretation of what is
taking place this may have played a hole
with the case of boxer lion and a few
well-known case but I think that he's a
very contrary personal conviction from
Ricky Kyung and also teaching thing that
we need to do something for the sake of
the country we are going to lose
credibility if we keep having this
corruption and they make every where we
are losing credibility people won't
trust us anymore opposition will become
very fragile so we need to clean up your
image and to give to the civil society
of civil society do not exist with a
better to the to the general public
persons that we are clean people at the
top
and so and that is a now they may also
catch up a few of the political and also
also who the sinker can create to give a
bad idea to others some intellectuals
some journalists are some NGOs some
activists we rock the rapper because it
can also create problem what we need to
do is to keep power and to keep power
with the country like this it is not
that easy and we had better to do
something to improve image because
otherwise you will remember history
Easter retailers that what happened in
the past was all well because of
corruption corruption has rolled down a
number of previous Emperor in the past
so we really need to be careful about
this and now that he has a full power he
can clean it can do it so there is
certainly some element to catch this one
but that's not certain we cannot
summarize this activity just to clean up
my adversary and put them into the box
here's my question alittle perjure yeah
um well I think fun found a business a
point of view it definitely adds some
challenges will it do business because
no especially if you're used to deal
with the government and you know the old
relationships will you build a trust you
build those people are gone there and it
solves that you don't know i think what
is add uncertainty to the policy
especially you know if the change is so
huge and you keep wondering you know
yeah simply press and positively people
develop you know what to do business
with doona i will know how to do it but
now this system does not work anymore so
i still want to do business with her but
what you said
especially if you're dealing with the
garment business and beautiful business
you know we got to be careful that but i
think the enterprise in China are used
to this yeah it isn't it's not like a
Neil you know it always has been this
way yeah question okay Oh as a company
grows and becomes a public company in
China for a while there was a real back
lash in the Nasdaq against Chinese
companies listing here because they were
too opaque you couldn't really see the
internal accounting so well do you see
this changing is this starting to become
more transparent in the Chinese
companies now and is this part of the
same thing are the leaders of the
companies now liable for criminal
problems if the company is sort of not
clean well I think if you look at the
trend the definitely company wants to be
more transparent and be professional
burn be more ethical the entire
countries also like that you know
anti-corruption so we'll make the way
you deal in business more compliant to
this you know ethical way and I see the
in terms of the Western view to the
Chinese company there there's always
some opaque doesn't understand that the
understanding is always like that but
there's a way like prior to two thousand
seven or you know when we actually my
company were planning to go I appeal
here that time is like the Western world
is the wide open they accept chinese
companies you see this so many companies
no one public into the nasdaq but then
you know in my industry is one bad
company you know and then the entire
viewpoint just changed and pretty much
at that time all of them our competitors
who went to the US company their stock
went rotten to like nothing and they
have to be privatized and taken back and
doing some restructuring or something
yeah yeah and and all suddenly become
the only public company you know but now
you know see Ali Baba you see new
companies and now i think you know
Western worded also again start opening
the real point because there are some
great companies you know when public
here and so okay another question from
the floor one of the former Chinese
leaders i think it was deng xiaoping
when asked what do you think of the
French Revolution replied we're not sure
yet that was two hundred-plus years
after the events so with that in mind
can you help us understand both of you
do macroeconomists have to write a new
textbook because of the fantastic
success in China in a new economic
system in the u.s. grievance struggling
to define it some people call it market
socialism other people call it communist
capitalism any thoughts over one level
that's a really huge question right I
mean are we redefining economics are you
kind of more specific to this whole idea
of what is the impact of the current
economic change well the corruption
crackdown you could argue is move
towards you know a traditional form of
capitalism wing theory and the West
would be that's been talked about in
regards to China for decades since you
can't have true capitalism until you get
Democratic with one hmm well of course I
have I have posted that intensity
venture to this because as we had said
it's a very complex and how did you I'll
give you my answer in a second but maybe
doin you want to speak first you know
yes we talked about China in term of a
social capitalism capitalism with
Chinese carrot say all kind of words to
try to go to capture see a sense of a
system which is a mix of capitalist
system but not universities in many ways
but at the same time it is a communities
that were not relate more socially but
so anyway so I think if you your
question is more what is likely to
happen I think they are today is three
dominance and argue once
yo is that they're just wait for
Hawaiian progressively because of the
globalization process and technological
evolution the north or influence of the
West China will become whole they sively
more and more like us because there's a
travel malls that go around the world
the progressively have access to
Internet to the rest of the war so that
will change the mindset and the system
will evolve institution will be
developed and it will be more democratic
system so now you're one scenario tube
is this system cannot last it going to
blow up you know that we have because of
the structure of the population because
of the emergence of the middle class
because of the people are moving to
order part of the world and coming back
with new idea or the student coming back
from the West American University and
all this is going to create and thanks
to internet and micro blog it will
create a movement and it will the system
will blow up and at the same time yoga
session the difficulties in Europe and
the US will fit oblem in China China
will have economic difficulty political
difficulties and then succeed ability at
the top so anyway it is the collapse of
the system possibly a little bit bhutan
and so forth so that scenario it is a no
no no no no no they they would have way
to cope with this they have a very
strong control system with different
kinds of a police or server otherwise as
they will be able to control those men a
manifestation or demonstrations around
her as they will control and what will
happen is that we have a capitalist
system in the from the outside we will
have a system which will be a kind of
Singapore with the steroids you know we
can big Singapore Lee Kuan Yew with a
very strong hand controlling and not
letting he leave a democratic process
developed to quickly and at the same
time with a market-oriented a marketer
directed not the hand of the government
and they said that it may happen which
will be the original system those in the
West we think that the democracy is a
bound to happen there is no choice it
will come necessarily and the wizard
when you have the middle income level
you will want a democracy so so it will
go to a democracy I think this theory is
our challenge very significantly so that
is a certain hour to force us in our
heroes if there is one is that something
will happen from an enlightened
leadership whether it is with this one
of the next generation in the eight
years from now and we will manage the
transition they will progressively
create mini party or democratic
democracy at different levels reelection
and progressive rate will come so they
will smoothly develop into a democratic
process I let you choose the most of all
I'm actually going to ask to move on to
a different topic because that's a great
answer jun there's one topic i really
want to make sure we get to today and
I'd like to start with you on this what
does this mean for people doing startups
here in Silicon Valley will it be is it
a good time to try to get into China or
because it's an economic slowdown people
will be a little bit less willing to
work with outside companies less willing
to let outside companies get into the
China market once how do you see this
affecting American entrepreneurs
especially Silicon Valley entrepreneurs
oh i think is a great time to to start a
company in china or if you're if you're
born in china and you get a study here
you want to go back that's a perfect
time you know a few huge cap capitals or
like that and we're supporting the
startups like that but if you are you're
not you don't have any Chinese
background you have a start up here you
want to grow your marketing to China and
then you need to have the right strategy
because the what I means you need to
have the right team to operate in China
because the the user behaviors is a come
competitive landscape is very different
in China and if you were born here you
don't have Sh end how the user behaves
and how the competition is like there
you're unlikely to be successful yeah
okay excellent go ahead I'm doing my PhD
here right now the third electrical
engineering you know just a follow-up
question can you mention describe more
about the right team I was at the
doesn't mean getting a stronger Chinese
person on your team so are you thinking
about the happiness out of your hand
yeah I'm working on it yeah well I
soluti when when China when the investor
look at the the team in China people is
the first you know the market is second
and I single avicii here in in u.s. may
reverse the priority and so the people
that how strong your team needs and are
mostly important thing and they will
look at your background and you know if
your technology companies the technical
capabilities and also the way how how
well you can execute in China is also
very important the learning capabilities
usually I think in the philosophy in
China is a little different here is
usually we look at the founders or CEOs
how strong that person is how the
founder team can carry unlike here you
know the VCS that they can change to a
professional manager to team you know
but in China because the market policies
are so it can change overnight aces you
know so you see always rely on the
founder to kind of carry the team
forward so that's why the founder team
is so important and be able to execute
fast and be able to understand the
market that's very important yeah
because the operational excellence in
china isn't very working if you want to
succeed there so we've got time for
about one more question from the floor
it not I have a question to end this up
with and that is how do you think that
we're going to see a proposed
tional slowdown in start-up companies as
the economy slows from ten percent to
seven percent are we actually going to
see more startup companies in China and
actually sort of where's that how's the
resources going to reallocate and June
why don't you take that first and only
Claude about really are we going to see
more entrepreneurism in China over the
next 10 years I mean it's been an
incredibly entrepreneurial plays right
for the last however many years June
what's your take um that's again it's a
difficult question I will say I am able
to predict on that what happened in next
10 years but i would say the
entrepreneur so we'll always will happen
and probably more so now and in the
future in the past because if you look
at the trend of the countries and the
policies are supporting their have the
policy more opening up for example they
allow the private on the bank that you
know the crowdfunding and you know
different areas and they start opening
the the new policy to allow private
startups to to happen so that's why i
think if you look at this trend that the
entra startups would come and also
because of the economic restructuring
the government needs support you know in
order to support employment they will
rely on the new starters coming up but
you're over a year there is always you
know wave right and right now i think
the current currently the valuation
china is pretty high the asset elasa to
the pretty high we don't know when it
will cool down or whether it will
Coulomb but at some point they might
have a adjustment I don't know when it
will come but you know isn't but
business always have cycle right so and
some of the great companies actually
start doing the downtime right now
professor Tibetan year comments about
where we're going from here I think
subscribe to what the June is suggesting
I think it is a quite a good time to go
into China follows out app that we
developed our so many as usage so many
opportunities I think the business is
going to become a little bit more
transparent not as transparent as we
would like it to be possibly but as what
is taking place today is going to reduce
somewhat the opacity of the network and
decision making process and in that
sense it will make a for a start-up may
be less difficult it will be you system
which will be theirs distant from the
one that we know on this side and second
you mentioned that the situation will
create more ethical management marching
possibly and if that is the case it will
also reduce little bit difficulties to
open it and to your question but what
kind of team do you need I think it will
give you a good answer i would say that
you were started by entrepreneur I
getting from the Silicon Valley to go to
work in Beijing in the one of the ink
you develop this business in Beijing we
need that you have a good insight into
the way the system function the capacity
to empathize with the system because
even if the system is changing it does
not necessarily make it easier to
understand because the dynamics of
changes has a complex and we need to
have an entrepreneur where's the sense
of feel for what is happening and the
fact that is an oversea Chinese having
been living in United States for the
last 15 or 20 years does not necessarily
make him the most emphatic to the
particular environment so I think we
should choose people who have this
capacity to understand the local
environment and now to esata to get the
signal with the need to develop the
startup and transfers don't know how an
abscess entrepreneurial Drive that we
need I think that's a wonderful comment
to close on today about empathy for the
system and the situation there please
join me in a warm round of applause for
our great panel
you